hi there this is John Green and I'm Hank
green and we are the vlogbrothers on
YouTube and we are making this video a
frequently asked questions video for the
purposes of answering some questions
that are frequently and people are often
confused like for example what is a
nerdfighter on nerdfighter is a person
who instead of being made out of like
bones and skin and tissue is made
entirely of Awesome so you're saying
that nerdfighters don't fight nerds no
we're clearly pro nerd nerdfighter is
basically just the community to sprung
up around our videos and basically we
just get together to try to do awesome
things and have a good time and fight
against world suck what's world suck
world suck is kind of exactly what world
suck sounds like it's hard to quantify
exactly but you know it's like the
amount of suck in the world one of the
questions we get asked the most is do
you guys have real jobs yes well it
depends on how you define real hank runs
the environmental technology website eco
geek John Green is an award-winning
author he has written books such as
Looking for Alaska and abundance of
katherines and Paper Towns and he's won
many awards including the Edgar Award
and the Prince award
why don't you blink I don't blink
because I'm focusing when I'm in front
of the camera I do blink in real life
that's why I still have eyes and also
it's sort of a tribute to the original
video blogger our hero
Zay frame so Hank what's dftba
dftba is an acronym no it isn't it is
not an acronym acronyms are
pronounceable it is an initialism dipped
bar okay
it's an initialism that stands for don't
forget to be awesome
am I too young old that skinny weird
cool nerdy and some tall dead to be a
nerdfighter no if you want to be a
nerdfighter you are a nerdfighters
nerdfighter dictionary time
lightning-round puppy-sized elephants we
ask natural selection to make us
puppy-sized elephants because they would
have the evolutionary advantage of being
adorable and we are waiting for that to
happen stuff on heads yeah if you put
stuff on your head it makes you feel
better about life nerdfighter gatherings
is when nerdfighters get together
sometimes we're there sometimes we're
not French the llama French the llama is
something that John is trying to make
into a thing and which people say French
the llama that whale is big but it's not
going to work oh it's gonna happen I'm
gonna make french the llama happen puffs
levels my puffs
is the level of puff in my hair which
gets higher as I get more stressed out
Decepticon is the opposite of a
nerdfighter giant squid of anger it's
basically like a YouTube troll tiny
chicken disease is a disease that
happens when there's tiny chickens in
your head and they lay eggs and all of
it goes out of your nose
it's actually it's a common cold yeah
secret siblings secret siblings are
anyone who makes video responses down
here to our videos down here in my pants
in your pants in your pants is a
phenomenon discovered by Maureen Johnson
if you add in your pants to the end of
book titles those book titles become
much funnier the Sun Also Rises in your
pants a spot of bother and your pants
not some not some is the opposite of
Awesome see also fail puppy and the fail
boat the Yeti is my wife the Catherine
is my wife oh and this ah is the
nerdfighter gang sign so if you see
somebody doing this you know that not to
shoot them we have created a playlist of
20 blog brothers videos that you can
watch that will give you a broader sense
of what's going on in nerdfighteria in
case you're new and a few of your
friends that are a little bit confused
about why you're watching two nerds make
videos about Star Wars and giraffe love
and making the world a better place
through video those those are three
interconnected ideas then you can send
them to this video right here so that
they can get a little bit of a debrief
before plunging in to the rest of our
stuff now the playlist is on the screen
and we got to do how to play the song
boo boo boo yeah did you just write that
because that's really good if that's
brilliant did you I do come up with that
off the top of your head like it's like
Mario swimming nerdfighteria thanks for
being awesome and thanks for all the
support you've given us as we continue
into our fourth year of making videos
best wishes
dftba